you
hi I'm here with my brothers teleson
edmundo we're the founders of a steam
for the guys prank Zeno Clash and rock
of ages and for this video we wanted to
show you a brief introduction our latest
game a bass odyssey one of the key
features of this game is the randomly
generated environments created through
hundreds of different building blocks
the combined pieces allow for hundreds
of different layouts of this Odyssey
paarl several elements from roguelike
games we're probably one of the most
important aspects about the gameplay of
this title is inclusion of a deep
fighting engine into it to the action
platformer and this is very interesting
because for enemies we basically have a
roster of fighters for instance if
you're fighting a skeleton in the game
it's not just a simple enemy that moves
forward the backwards or maybe just
punches and froze bones it's a complex
AI with an equivalent move set to your
own
when testing the enemy movesets we
realize that one of the most fun things
you could do in the game display as the
enemy characters so we introduced the
power for the hero characters where you
can capture the soul of enemies and
later use those enemies to play the game
here you can see the player capturing
become a widow in this bull can do combo
long hairy dog do back air neutral air
forward air attacks Castle to a special
playing the adventure with each
different character feels completely
different we hope you enjoyed this brief
introduction to abyss odyssey stay tuned
for upcoming videos where we will talk
about more unique features on the game